we've always seen Europe as a as a hub
for us because actually you know we have
a bigger outbound feeder market actually
coming into our hotels in Asia in the
Middle East and most of the Europeans
you know it's it's one of our biggest
client segments and therefore like you
know we've always wanted to have to be
in Europe as a for us to have a good
brand presence as well so we've we've
been looking at Europe for a long long
time and we were quite lucky to to to
enter Europe sort of last year so we are
in Portugal and also we've managed to
get into South America as well what
about the UK does that figure all new on
your radar of course because UK's is a
big market for us and also UK itself I
think it's one of the it's one of the
great cities to live in and and and it's
got so much to offer in terms of culture
in terms of diversity from a tourism
perspective and form a hospitality
perspective so so UK we've always seen
UK as as a hub for us in terms of
investments so you anticipate opening
slides here by one yes we we've been
looking at UK now for the last two years
since we've managed to get into Europe
so I hope within the next two years will
have something here in the UK then that
never seems to be a week goes by without
some sort of terror incident somewhere
in the world how are you navigating your
way through that and how do you see
tourists reacting at the moment when you
look at tools and today and when you
look at the travel you know people are
quite resilient and you know there's
always something somewhere in the world
and whether we like it or not we have to
live with it and it's something you have
to embrace and it's something you have
to be careful about of course but at the
same time you know the guests today are
much more resilient and and and they are
open to travel and whatever happens you
know like you know from where we come
from you know that we've had some
catastrophe almost every year but if
every single time you know Thailand has
always come come
very strong and and it's the same thing
you know people will love to go to these
places and in terms of opening hotel in
the UK or not deterred by brexit at all
we're not actually you know I think we
always see you know during a crisis you
see opportunities as well and for us you
know the timing is perfect because from
an investment perspective the UK pound
is is is low it's at its low it which is
quite attractive to some of the Asian
investors as well and the market is
still booming like you know when you
look at some of the tourism statistics
you know it's it's still high and yes I
think you know these things are it's
very short term and things come and go
and it will correct itself fairly soon